four day work week good idea bad idea I
asked this on Twitter 25 000 people
voted for do they care about it is it a
bad idea is it a good idea the results
will probably surprise you
[Music]
so I got to tell you I was surprised
because my audience is generally
entrepreneurs COC Suite most of these
guys are in business a lot of them are
more than the average person I thought
the numbers were going to be fully a
horrible idea but this is what happened
twenty two and a half percent said they
don't care 23 is a bad idea
54.6 said it is a good idea I don't know
about you but I'm Blown Away by the
results four-day work week what do you
want to do with the three days is it
good for you is it even healthy for you
to have more time on your hands when we
have more free time do we live longer
Are we more fulfilled is it worse for us
you'd be amazed by the results by the
way we got a lot of different data I
want to see if any other country did the
four day work week did they get good
results when we did that we found out
which country in the world works the
least amount of hours a week by the way
it's 29 hours I'll tell you here in a
minute who it is and then maybe it's
some Industries I'll give you my
argument you make a decision for
yourself having said that let's get
right into it so before we go into some
of these countries that are testing a
four-day work week let's define success
what is success here is it success just
having more time within countries that
do that and are given to people more
time that's called successful to you but
it's success more countries that are
doing a model that produces more
companies that generate jobs that create
better Innovation if that's success with
a lot of these countries that are doing
afford to work with you get an effort
first I believe we have to Define what
success is and then we'll look at the
data so now when I give you some of
these countries I'm also going to give
you what companies that founded there
what technology has been started there
and then you can say well based on your
definition Patrick I disagree with you I
think they're doing it better or based
on your definition I think this four day
work week is a terrible idea so
Australia number one more than 20
companies will take part of a four day
work week trial this is something
they've been testing they're calling it
the four day week Global which is a
non-profit organization that's also
overseeing pilots in UK and New Zealand
FYI Australia two big names
technology-wise that I came out of there
one is Wi-Fi 1992 and the other one is
Google Maps which was invented by Danish
Brothers in Australia later bought by
Google all right that's their Innovation
Austria according to an oecd report
Austria has the sixth shortest average
work week in the world 35 and a half
hours a week a lot of people would say
they were already doing that and
although Austria hasn't instituted a
four-day Work Week many Austrian workers
are interested in the idea matter of
fact they surveyed people to ask who was
interested in it one out of every two
workers said they would welcome a four
day work week so now let's define
success Austria you ready most
Innovative company they have started in
the last 30 something years it's called
Pez candy you ever seen Pez candy you
probably had it before you know what the
top line revenue was last year 29
million bucks yes 29 million dollars
that's Innovation if that's success to
you or maybe the four day work week is a
great idea let's go to the next country
Belgium workers in Belgium now have the
right to switch to a four-day work week
but they're working for 10 hour days
which is a total of 40 hours a week and
although workers in Belgium have
traditionally worked a five-day work
week in early 2022 Belgian government
introduced a new labor market reform
that allows workers to choose to work a
four-day Work Week workers are still
expected to maintain the same amount of
hours but I have the option to work for
10 hour days workers are allowed to ask
their employers for a six-month trial
period of the four day work week after
which they can choose to go back to the
traditional five-day work week that's
Belgium by the way if I were to ask you
what innovation has Belgium done in the
last 30 years or something you're going
to say well they got the best beer and
they got great candy and they got great
this and they got Anheuser-Busch and
they got yeah maybe but no real crazy
Innovation that impacted other countries
positively again how do you define
success next Canada population 38
million dozens of companies in Canada
are experimenting with a four day work
week as part of the four-day work with
global pilot in early 2022 Canada began
the four day work weekly trial just to
kind of see how it's going to work out
well the goal of the program is to
demonstrate that employees can maintain
100 of productivity while working 20
fewer hours and receiving the same
amount of pay I don't know give me
Innovation from Canada Google Facebook
Apple who who from Canada don't know
this Canada known as The Innovation cap
of the world probably not how do you
define success let's go to the next
country Denmark population 5.8 million
according to an oecd report Denmark has
the second shortest average work week in
the world 33 hours a week if you like
working only 33 hours a week go to
Denmark they tested this to see what was
going to happen this allowed full-time
workers in Denmark to spend 66 percent
of their day on rest and Leisure by the
way they switched to a five-day Work
Week model in the 30s previously was a
six day work week and now what a Denmark
invent I Gotta Give these guest props
Legos I love Legos so listen Denmark if
you're going to work 33 hours a week and
still produce the Legos you keep doing
what you're doing right now leave The
Innovation to other countries next
Germany population 83.2 million people
in addition to having won the shortest
work weeks in the world 34 hours
Germany's largest Trade union is
lobbying for Germany to adapt to what
they work with since 2020 Germany has
faced economic difficulties from both
the pandemic and the struggles to
transition to electric vehicles what
kind of innovation has Germany produced
obviously they got the cars we all know
the cars that they produce but airbags a
sea leg the chip on your credit card the
MP3 format that's what Germany has done
is it a good idea to go to four day work
week and only work 34 hours a week
that's what Germany wants to do that's
what Germany wants to do doesn't
necessarily make it a good idea here's
another one for you Iceland they got 372
000 people living in the largest pilot
of a four-day Work Week took place in
Iceland with two and a half people
taking part of to study Iceland is one
of the country's most in support of the
four-day work week between 2015 and
2019. Iceland LED one of the largest
four-day Work Week Pilots the trial was
considered a huge success and has
resulted in a huge shift in Iceland's
standard working hours with 90 percent
of population currently enjoying reduced
hours or other work modifications
fantastic let's move to Iceland
anyways awesome job Iceland proud of you
guys this next one's going to surprise
you because it's Japan 126 million
people living there the government
released their annual economic policy in
2021 which recommended that company's
let staff work four days a week instead
of five although in the past Japan has
been known for an intense working
culture recently the country has
released the new guidelines encouraging
this the four day work week has been
proposed in the past and implemented by
some companies such as Microsoft Japan
however the covid-19 pandemic ready for
this and a labor shortage in the country
moved the government to promote it as a
nationwide guideline the goal of the
four-day workweek guideline is to
support employee Wellness family time
and social life help the country's labor
shortage what they've invented ready
emojis Walkman CDs DVD Blu-ray VHS jet
ski laptop 3D printing there's a lot of
different great things that they've done
in Japan but it sounds like kobit and a
lot of people complaining about it has
scared people in Japan to say instead of
losing these employees get them to work
four day a week I think it's going to
back far on them those of you that want
to have a four-day work week you are
going to love this next country ready
Netherlands you know how many hours a
week people work in this place 29
the freaking dream can you imagine
living in the Netherlands only work 29
hours a week in the Netherlands citizens
now have the right to go part-time in
their job unless there's substantial
business reasons justifying why they
cannot as a result workers in
Netherlands have the shortest average
working week in the world 29 hours
although Netherlands doesn't necessarily
have a four-day work week it's the norm
for many people especially working moms
according to government statistics 86
percent of employed moms work less than
35 hours per week 12 of working fathers
are also low hours compared to other
countries that's what they have you know
what they've invented Bluetooth
Netherlands thank you so good idea bad
idea again how do you define success but
think about it this way if you go from
five days a week to four days a week you
take one on five that's 20 what does it
mean you automatically increase the
shortage of workers by 20 so I as a
company owner operator CEO need to go
increase 20 of my employees pay the same
salary so they can make the cost of
living their expenses Family Mortgage
tax taxes Insurance how are we going to
do this so my cost just went up 20 and
you want me to still sell the products
at a discounted rate and that means I
have to increase my product cost by 20
so if the hamburger was 10 bucks now
it's 12 bucks if the car was 40 grand
out 48 Grand are you okay with that well
no no no no no that's not what we said
all we said is let people work only four
days a week how do you want me to make
the cars I need workers how do you want
to make the technology the computer the
TV four-day work week is a great Noble
consideration but it's going to backfire
let me give you another one
industry-wise could it work in certain
industries sure maybe some Industries
can do this can you work in all
Industries there's nowhere in the world
you can work this in all Industries
media you brought to break a story no no
no four-day work week we're not going to
break the story because it's a four-day
work with Pat that's an excuse you can
hire other people that are going to work
those days exactly I need to increase
labor by 20 so what why don't you do
stop being so greedy put the money into
the employees math doesn't work that way
have you rented a company there's this
guy who I interviewed damn price I
believe is his name he said I'm gonna
give all my employees 70 000 including
myself it backfired on the guy have you
heard the articles on this guy everybody
loved them what a noble man backfired
they don't work out for everybody
lawsuits from his own family issues HR
issues doesn't work but it was a great
story for socialists to use to go viral
with look at this guy so Noble look at
these billion they're so greedy right
okay let me continue I still haven't
sold you on it can it work out different
faces of a company maybe if it's a
Fortune 100 company that's worth half a
trillion dollars and they got all the
resources maybe you can is it a
mid-faced company that's been around for
20 years 30 years 40 years a billion
dollar companies maybe you can will it
work in a startup probably not do you
know what it's like to be part of a
startup imagine I start a company hey
guys we got this idea we're gonna go
take over this entire publishing
business and we're going to make books
people buy it online but don't worry
about it you're only going to work four
days a week for 29 hours because we're a
Noble company let's make this Amazon
company work really you really buy that
idea you think it's going to work with
startups what world do you live in if
you actually think that's going to
become an idea here's what's funny
journalists are convincing people that
this is possible and it's not they just
need an article to right and politicians
said let's do this because people are
going to like it I'm going to get
reelected let's keep selling this
concept here let's go to four day work
week catastrophic again not in all cases
it's not going to work in startup let me
give you this other argument so I'm
gonna Pat stop it oh my God why is it
all you guys care about is money no
problem okay if you want to pay my bills
out I don't have to worry about money if
you want to fulfill my dreams I don't
have to worry about all but here's a
thought for you as parents what do
parents say that I've raised great kids
keep them busy too much time on hand for
your kids is not a good thing well why
not why should kids go to school as much
as they do maybe we need to give kids
more time why they go to school from
eight in the morning to three o'clock
why not make it A2 11 o'clock give a
bunch of free time this is not cool why
are you making it so hard on the kids we
should do the same thing for kids as
well let them come home no I I don't
think that's a good idea why not you
want to afford a work week let's give
kids 40 work week no no it's better if
you keep your kids busy because the more
you keep them busy and they're doing
sports and after school activities they
don't do drugs they don't do drugs it's
better bingo I agree and you agree you
get what I'm saying like hey more people
having more idle time is that a good
thing let me share a study with you by
this lady Cassie mcgillner Holmes who is
a psychologist finding out to see the
more time we have in our hands are we
happy Are we more fulfilled or we're not
here's what she found out she did the
survey investigating 21 000 Americans
who responded to this question okay at
what point is it good at what point does
it backfire what she found out is if you
have less than two hours of free time
that's not good this is where you have a
lot of stress anything between two hours
is good right when you get about to five
hours or more it's not good okay you're
not happier why this is how they broke
it down they broke it on less than two
hours you feel like you're anxious
because you don't have enough time to
get all the other chores done anything
about five hours you feel like you're
not fulfilled because you're not making
a big impact in the world the idea to
make people fulfilled to do better
things is not giving them more time you
know what's the last thing and then when
I had a lot of time on my hands my hair
was orange did you hear what I said the
last time I had a lot of time on my
hands my hair was orange I was 21 years
old I got out of the army I was at
Venice speech every flipping day
partying doing the stuff I was doing I
do way too much time on my hands am I
better for society is that what you want
me to do you it's not a good idea here's
another one for you well Pat we should
get people to retire at 55 years old not
at 65. it's not good people need to
enjoy their retirement really have you
looked at the studies of what happens
when people retire early have you looked
at any of that stuff let me do the work
for and share it with you early
retirement before age of 62 has been
associated with higher mortality risk in
some instances in a study of Shell Oil
company found that those who retire at
55 years old live to be 65 die 37 sooner
than those that retire at 65 and in
general people retire at 55 ready for
this one this is not a good one our 89
more likely to die within 10 years than
those that retire at 65. Social Security
has noticed this trend as well men that
retire at 62 have a 20 percent higher
likelihood of death than the general
population go ahead let's get people to
retire less let's get kids to go to
school from 8 to 11. let's do 40 work
week five four let's go three days these
are not ideas that get a person to be
fulfilled bitterness comes from that I
no longer matter you no longer matter
it's tough to make a big impact when you
don't have the right amount of time to
do so by the way lot of people that are
going to disagree with me and those of
you who do you went to a school and a
professor convinced you that this was a
good idea you fell for it take your time
you're going to realize not a good idea
10 20 years from now anyway I understand
talking about stories that's going to do
very well let me write a book called
four day work week or four hour work day
and people are going to buy that's going
to do well of course people don't want
to work a lot of hours when I was
younger I don't want to work a lot of
hours but I realized life is more
valuable if you're in pursuit of
something and there's meaning to your
life just the same way we don't think
it's a good idea to have the kids only
go to school 8 to 11 and spend the rest
of the day with us at the house and not
have anything else to do because they
get in trouble and you and I did just
the same way we realize data tells us
it's not a good thing to retire too
early at 55. just the same way it's
going to be when people realize it's not
going to be a good idea for some
companies to go to four day work weeks
we'll the four day work week idea work
for certain companies certain niches
certain ideas certain industries sure is
it going to work if we define success by
Innovation and a company that creates
jobs and makes things better no it's not
going to work doing afford it work week
by the way tell people myself hey you
understand I hate my job okay maybe I
understand why you want to work four
days but if you've hated the last 10
jobs it's not a job it's you you got to
change your mindset you're the problem
not the job not the industry your
mindset people sold you on having said I
got two things for you one if you want
to find out what drives you I created a
quiz here on pbdquiz.com if you've never
taken it will take you to find out
exactly which of the four different
factors you're driven by and the other
one is if you enjoy this content there's
another video I did about five six years
ago titled how to reach your full
potential if you've never watched it
like here to watch it take care
everybody
thank you